hey what's going on it's bill burr it's
time for the monday morning podcast for
monday
march 14th i'm doing it on the 15th i'm
buried in this movie i apologize and
this thing's only going to be a half
hour long just ride with me for the next
three weeks and then i'll be wrapped on
the movie uh we'll be doing podcast
sliders
you guys are gonna drop some pounds here
the next few weeks um
yeah i've just been busting my ass and
uh
i was gonna try to do the podcast sunday
night and um
or maybe monday i don't even know what
happened
monday
i ate a salad
you know because i'm trying to be in
actor shape and i [ __ ] and then i had
a slice of domino's pizza and i got all
of a sudden i felt bad i was just like
was that the domino's pizza and
everybody's you know on set's going well
dude you've been eating so clean you
probably got a lactose intolerance
you know from the pizza whatever i'm
like well you know you kind of have to
be like at least a 12 pack in for
dominoes to taste good or at least to
have an edible
you know so i was kind of blaming the
pizza and i got to tell you something i
got to apologize to domino's pizza it
wasn't the pizza it was the salad
and i ended up getting like some low
level of food poisoning
um
dude i gotta tell you something
um i went to bed that night and had to
get up like three times an hour the
whole night and it was the x the
exorcist
and the sequel at the same time if you
know what i mean let's just say uh uh
the salad utilized every exit
but what was amazing
was i got this great night's sleep
despite getting up what felt like two to
three times an hour because i was so
exhausted my body was so worn out from
fighting this thing that my big head
would hit the pillow and i would
immediately just hit rem sleep
and i woke up
i was weak as hell and my lower back was
killing me from convulsing over the
[ __ ] toilet i mean
like this [ __ ] would not stop coming out
until it was just bile
um but i gotta tell you something i
don't mind puking well i know a lot of
people they hate puking i actually
i think the noises you make are [ __ ]
hilarious when you go
you know when you get really
towards whatever is left
you know just laugh i was kind of
cracking up and then uh
and then after you puke you feel so much
better
you feel so much better like uh
underrated
underrated the feeling right after
puking
and i'm not talking about the
embarrassment or shame you know if
you're like a [ __ ] parking lot
you know before a game tailgating i mean
that's that's kind of that's not a good
feeling but like you know
there's just something in your body and
your body wants it out of you puking's
also underrated because it's getting it
out way quicker than on the other end
because the other end it got into you it
went through the whole thing you know it
kind of got past that first line of
security
and then it got into your intestines and
that's when people start whispering what
the [ __ ] is this and then
all right buddy
it's time for you to go right and that's
it right
that actually my jim brewer used to have
this great [ __ ] bit
about your stomach puking
something with the stomach was like the
bouncer and it got everybody out of the
club
wow
i just went back almost 30 years in the
[ __ ] comedy brain there
um anyway
so um
so you know what you do after you have a
night of that [ __ ] and puking and
everything you know if you're a big
hollywood phony the first thing you do
when you wake up what do you do do you
get some electric electrolytes do you
drink some gatorade no you jump on the
scale and you're like
dropped two and a half pounds baby
i know it's sad it's pathetic but it is
what it is i'm recording this on my
phone because i can't find my other
thing because my life is a mess right
now but um
i will tell you this the the movie is
going
uh it's going amazing it's really going
amazing and i got a very nice letter
from the people that gave us the money
saying how much they're enjoying the
daily so i don't know i'm getting a
little excited here
getting a little excited what's going on
out in the world
only thing i know is the gas prices are
high
which this is yet another time where i
thought i would just wish regular people
were organized
you know
it's like we told we made we made
the gas prices go down to like two bucks
a gallon a dollar 90 a gallon in 2020
by all staying home and not driving
granted the government told us to stay
home i ain't [ __ ] staying home i
don't trust the government
um
they're bombing iraq that's great
support the troops
um
anyway uh
you know we made it go down so why don't
we just all just like drive less
if you're working somewhere and somebody
lives kinda near you why don't you
commute [ __ ] these gas companies
okay they keep doing this [ __ ] where it
was like they didn't know the pandemic
was coming so they had all of this fuel
and then we didn't use it
so the supply and demand thing so then
we we start buying it again and then
what do they do they stop producing it
and then they're like oh we don't have
as much
they do it on purpose they're greedy
[ __ ] they pay all the politicians the
republicans
the blue ties the obamas the trumps the
bidens the clintons they pay all of them
they pay all of them
you know and
so they don't do anything about it but
we have we have the power man
but you get the power then you don't
drive your car
then you get the girl right we have the
power to just make it go back down again
just don't [ __ ] drive if you can or
whatever commute with somebody else
all right
do your part this week to [ __ ] over the
[ __ ] oil companies and drive less or
commute or stay home one day when you
were gonna go out or ride your bike do
something like that [ __ ] these [ __ ]
greedy [ __ ]
who create a shortage on purpose so they
can try to make up all the money they
lost in 2020.
it's [ __ ] disgusting
i saw a thing the other day you know
they're trying all these [ __ ]
trumpsters are trying to say that donald
trump was right about the [ __ ] oil
and all of that [ __ ] it's [ __ ]
hilarious
he was right about the oil yeah well so
was jimmy carter but he wore the wrong
color [ __ ] tie right jimmy carter
made that same [ __ ] speech in the
late 70s
said this country is addicted to oil he
put solar panels on the [ __ ] white
house
and he was viewed as weak
and then 40 [ __ ] years later a guy
with a red tie says the same god damn
thing minus the solar panels and he's
considered a [ __ ] god by the same
people that thought the other guy was a
[ __ ] weak person
all right now i'm not just going after
conservatives here because if the exact
same thing happened reverse where a red
tie guy said it
the blue tie people won't listen to it
what are you saying here bill i don't
know what i'm saying
i'm just i don't know
it's [ __ ] unbelievable all you got to
do is have a [ __ ]
different colored tie and people get
like hypnotized and they won't [ __ ]
listen to it oh gee bill you're so
goddamn smart i know i know but i think
i do make some good points here all
right everybody it's indochino you know
from weddings to work functions to
weekends out of the town it's always the
right time to dress to impress
especially in clothes that fit you
perfectly
indochino makes high quality custom
fitted suits shirts and casual wear all
it is surprisingly affordable price oh
you look at that
um you can customize everything from
suits and shirts to chinos and bomber
jackers jackets at prices more
affordable than you might expect
indochino offers completely custom
fitted suits shirts casual wear and more
surprisingly affordable prices get a
wardrobe personalized to your style and
taste without spending a fortune every
piece is made to your exact measurements
and you can custom
you can customize every detail
choose everything from about your suit
including the fabric lapel monogram and
statement linings make a statement with
your lining create a suit that fits you
and your style perfectly they're always
adding new pieces so you can uh stay on
trend and in style the best part
indochino suits start from just 4 29.
and shirts it's set from 79
this season dress to impress on every
occasion with indochino get 50 off any
purchase of 3.99 or more by using the
promo code bur at indochino.com that uh
that's 50 off a purchase of 399 or more
at ind
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o dot com promo code bur
oh look who it is everyone it's true
bill do you know why why free trials
renew without your consent it's a
business scam out to get you
don't let greedy corporations pocket
your money download true bill to take
control of your subscriptions this is a
great idea true bill is the new app that
helps you identify and stop paying for
subscriptions you don't need want or
simply forgot about on average people
save up to 720 dollars a year
with true bill because companies make
subscriptions hard to cancel true bill
makes it incredibly simple just link
your accounts and true bill will cancel
your unwanted subscriptions in one tap
and your true build concierge is there
when you need them to cancel unwanted
subscriptions so you don't have to
truebill has over 2 million users and
helped save them over 100 million
dollars like matthew b
maddie b what do you say there he says
in a matter of seconds i say 660 dollars
for the year on my directv bill saved
120 for the year on my serious xm bill
saved 840 a year on car insurance
don't fall for subscription scams man
start canceling today at truebuild.com
go right now truebill.com
it could save you thousands a year
truebuild.com
read some of the uh the questions
some of the questions here
um
no some of the uh the advice here now i
you know i said
for the final time
you know john bonham's a better drummer
than ginger baker he just is for what
he's doing he's playing rock music he's
better all right
ginger baker had more in his vocabulary
you know he could do the jazz drummer
thing but as one of my friends said was
he one of the greatest jazz drummers of
all time no he was not
all right
tony williams [ __ ] smoked that guy
alvin jones smoked that guy max roach
smoked that guy buddy rich smoked that
guy but as far as rock drummers go john
bonham's the greatest of all time
all right that's my opinion dear bill
dear bill bonham thanks for being such a
funny bastard i've managed to get my mom
hooked on your specials and she always
puts them on whenever i visit oh that's
really nice i really dig your
discussions on drumming and music in
general too
um and as far as the question oh let me
talk about something right now you know
there's a show out right now called uh
pam and tommy
where they really try to make tommy lee
out to be this really like sort of dumb
guy
and um which is really a shame because
if you listen to the guy's drum parts
in uh all of his work
throughout his career motley crew
throughout everything he's a [ __ ]
genius
and i know a lot of drummers out there
you know they get into how difficult
something is and the technicality and
what time signature it's in
like what that guy does he plays for the
[ __ ] song
i was listening to that wild side today
and just how he um that little break
when the band cuts out before they go
into the chorus how each time how he
brings up the intensity of what he's
doing to to build the momentum of the
song and the originality and the drum
parts that fit [ __ ] perfectly with
the song
okay you're not you're not a
mouth-breathing [ __ ]
um
i do know it's just a tv show but that's
been bugging me because i got to be
honest with you whenever i sit down to
try and learn a motley cruise song i am
always blown away by the drum part like
what the [ __ ] did he come up with that
you know and there's a lot of [ __ ] out
there young [ __ ] that are on [ __ ]
youtube that you know you're just
getting spoon fed all of these [ __ ]
licks and then you sit down and you
learn how to play them and then you
connect them all together and you play
90 [ __ ] miles an hour and you think
you're [ __ ] better than these guys
but like when somebody comes in with the
guitar riff and you actually have to
come up with a a drum part that not only
fits it complements it and elevates it
that's an entirely different thing
um
having said that a lot of the young
drummers do [ __ ] blow me away but i
think that's becoming a lost art
where it's just becoming chops because
these kids today when i tell you these
goddamn kids the way they play i mean
their chops are [ __ ] unbelievable
um all right here we go as far as the
question of baker versus bonham i find
that ginger's playing as a little more
dialed back
not boring but his energy is definitely
on a shorter leash than bottoms i can
see how his fills leave something to be
desired that being said his solos are
really well spaced no solos are
incredible
uh they have a certain galloping quality
that i find hypnotic i wouldn't argue
with that his solo and blind faith's
live performance of
do what you like at hyde park
illustrates what i'm getting at i
recently watched that no i do think he's
amazing but i mean
we're talking about the genre of rock
that's you know i got to give it to bono
john is the ma is the man though i don't
think ginger's comments about him not
being able to swing a bag of [ __ ] were
called for yeah i thought that was just
all jealousy
i guess that's just how old jazz dudes
looked at other musicians though we all
know how [ __ ] great those triplets
are
uh what about the purdy shuffle he plays
on fool in the rain or cashmere
it blew my feeble human mind when i
found out he was playing in a different
time signature from the rest of the band
in that song
is that true i didn't even know that
i honestly love both players so much but
ginger's overly salty attitude
gives him a deduction in my book yeah
that really is a shame because everybody
looked at him like he was one of the
greatest of all time
you know so he should have just taken
the compliments instead of being a [ __ ]
and [ __ ] trash and
all these other people that were getting
compliments
gee i know a few people like that
i've been like that um i'd like to
acknowledge mitch mitchell from the jimi
hendrix hendrix experience as an
honorable mention too yeah he was a
[ __ ] beast um he had those same jazz
roots and vibes as ginger but he
definitely had a brighter and more
livelier personality in his playing i
could listen to his parts on manic
depression over and over uh anyways
that's all i really have to say looking
forward to your future projects you know
i
those are all great points i think i
would get more into mitch mitchell i
just feel like the recording of that
music
it's really muddy and i feel like it
exists somewhere between before stereo
and after stereo
where um
you know his drums are really low in the
mix
i feel
or maybe my ears aren't good enough to
pick up
i mean i know the guy's you know killing
it or whatever but
i like when i i watch when i want to
watch mitch mitchell i try to watch
something on youtube where he's playing
live because then i feel like
everything's at the same level and um
i can really hear what he's doing all
right driverless future
dear billy goodyear i'm not sure if
you're following this but there's a push
by certain agencies and private equity
groups people with lots of money
sometimes with lobbyists behind them to
ban the use of self-driving cars
granted it would be years till this
happened if it did what are your
thoughts on this
my first thought is
what are the what's their problem with
the way we're doing it
you know i know there's a lot of bad
drivers out there
i know that you know
i don't i don't know i feel like there's
too many people so we got to have
certain people get taken out by car
accidents that's too dark i can't say
that and the deer population would be oh
what were the [ __ ]
over the goddamn horizon anyway the
learning curve of a.i would mean that
the first few years
could yield more accidents than manual
human drivers dude i am not getting in a
car
that's like sitting at the front of the
train like the conductor and you see
that other train coming at you and
you're like
that's your last moment i want to be in
the back
in the dining car going can i get a
turkey sub with some lay's chips please
boom lights out
uh
i think i'd i'd hate to have to be told
what road to drive down to justify to my
car system that i need to pull over to
send a text make a call or eat a
sandwich on a side street or maybe even
some teenage funny stuff what are you
talking about if it's self-driving you
could be banging in the car dude people
are gonna be [ __ ] in the car
texting
shaving
uh i'm not against progress but i see
the death of romance coming
uh there's something romantic about
being able to travel freely wanted to
get your big brain take i know that was
[ __ ] sarcastic congrats on your
beautiful family thank you um
yeah i don't know what that is about
um the only thing that i could see about
that is the people that are
are behind it have a lot of money in
self-driving cars
and there's some sort of thing in there
and and it will all be done
out of concern for our own safety
you know what i mean and then it'll take
it you know they'll say like well when
you get on a plane
you don't fly the plane there's a pilot
you know when you get on a boat you have
a you have a captain and you get on a
train you have a [ __ ]
conduct not a conductor what do you call
an engineer
right
they'll say that [ __ ] um
i have to tell you driving my old ford
truck
you know
on like a sunday
the window down and it's manual and it
shifts on the column it's just one of
the great joys i have in life
and uh i'm gonna teach my son and
daughter how to drive that truck
which i think is a really cool thing um
it is one of the cool things about
being an old dad is uh
you know you were around for a lot of
cool [ __ ] and your kids are gonna know
all the new [ __ ] they can teach you the
new [ __ ] and then you got all this cool
old [ __ ]
um
i mean i don't know how many kids
in my daughter and son's generation are
gonna know how to drive a stick shift
let alone one on the column that's
pretty [ __ ] cool i think
um
in fact i think my daughter's first car
i'll probably get her an old car
that has uh that's a stick shift
you know
just so her kids their friends can see
uh i don't know i'm a weirdo like that
like you know there's a mustang out
right now i went i saw it with dean del
rey that had looked like a hurst shifter
uh it was battleship gray and it was a
six-speed
um i was talking to dean we saw that
thing like [ __ ] six months ago he
goes dude i think of that car every day
um
yeah i don't know what
i i i do think that um
what basically happens as far as like
control goes over people the bigger the
the
the flock gets the more control they
need to have over people i feel
like back in the day you know when there
was only a couple hundred million people
you could you know
you could roam around and do basically
whatever the [ __ ] you wanted
even bad [ __ ] too
so i mean it was a much more dangerous
place
um
and then somewhere there was a tipping
point where i think now they're taking
like too much control
i don't know that's just i mean they're
going to have like self-flying planes
self-flying helicopters
they're moving towards that
um
[Music]
you know and they'll probably just blame
pilot error and and you know bad drivers
and [ __ ] like that
um but what it really comes down to is
it's always about money that's what i
would guess all right
plowing ahead here new segment uh
something you knew was too bad two
badass for you oh yeah i was saying like
i own i own like a [ __ ] couple of les
paul guitars
an sg or two
a three i have some really good guitars
that i you know bought and i love
playing the malcolm young parts of ac dc
but i have no business owner in those
[ __ ] guitars i have an old
rickenbacker left-handed bass i play
guitar left-handed so and then i got the
i got a
the gretch drums i feel like i deserve
those because i play them all the time
but uh the segment is what's what's
something badass that you own that you
know is too badass for you but you still
bought it hey yo billy red white and
bald head
uh this last thursday you were rambling
on about wanting a big-ass truck yeah i
want to get an f-250 regular cab with
the diesel engine
and all of that [ __ ] and i don't know
how to [ __ ] i change a light bulb
that's it i just [ __ ] love them uh
you asked about owning something super
badass but deep down knowing
yeah it's just not for you you weren't
bad badass enough to to uh
to own it i immediately knew i had a
story you'd appreciate when i was about
12 years old uh 2002 my dad bought
himself a 1966 ford mustang powder blue
with a white hard top mint condition the
kind of car seinfeld would have picked
your goofy ass up in before he invited
you
uh interviewed you about killing flies
um this car was immaculate my dad took
it to every car show he could find and
got first place every time completely
original the leather seats match the
paint job dude send a picture that
sounds beautiful still plays eight
tracks perfectly not one single scratch
on this [ __ ] thing you get it the car
was sexy as hell and everyone knew it i
turned 16 to get my driver's license
oh no at first i'm driving an old maroon
beat up mazda on its dying days nothing
special about it represented me well
unassuming uh never stands out in a
crowd gets the job done but no bells or
whistles one day out of the [ __ ] blue
my dad straight up hands me the keys to
his mustang he says it's mine
i'm 16.
oh my god
he goes i absolutely [ __ ] love that
car but for some reason i never felt
comfortable in it all of my friends
wanted to ride in it i turned heads
everywhere i went everyone was jealous
of me but deep down i was a stupid kid
with half a mustache it made me cr
incredibly insecure and i told my dad i
didn't want it anymore
oh my god i get it no dude i get that i
get that where i was when i was 16 i
[ __ ] didn't like myself i didn't like
who i was so the last thing i wanted was
people looking at me dude i can't tell
you how much that's what i got out of
that
um
you know when you think about the guys
that had the cool cars
in uh in high school aside from being
rich or whatever they also felt good
about themselves and they wanted people
to look at them and they felt good so
they look good in the car
you know if i got in the same car i'm
like
do i look cool i don't do i no i don't
and i have that insecurity and i want to
look like an [ __ ]
bill my dad sold it immediately after i
gave it to him a guy in france bought it
i'm from texas this french [ __ ] [ __ ]
literally had an 18-wheeler pick it up
from my house drive it all the way to
california from texas put it on a boat
why wouldn't he drive it to the east
coast and shipped it
to himself in france that's how valuable
this car was and i simply gave it up i'm
guaranteed to never see it again i will
never forgive myself for that
young and dumb right
no
no no you weren't young and dumb you
were just
you just were an insecure kid it was too
much of a car for where you were at
um your dad was obviously done with it
when he gave it to you
and uh yeah that's fine
listen i [ __ ] look i would have
looked like a jerk off in that car at
16. i look great in my truck now because
i love it i don't feel like an [ __ ]
and i'm happy as hell when i'm driving
and i don't care when people look at me
because you know i'm just an old bald
ginger i don't give a [ __ ] it's one of
the great things about getting older you
don't care what people think anymore
um anyways you're the man bill flew to
colorado to see you film your special
red rocks die hard fam for damn near a
decade i appreciate your wisdom
but more so i appreciate your ability to
make me feel better about my own level
of intellect
that's one of the coolest ways anybody
ever said i'm dumb uh take it easy and
my best to the family back east
uh go [ __ ] yourself you [ __ ]
all right that was a great story man
that's a great car story
um i hope that guy in france is
listening man send us a picture of the
car
um you know that guy's the coolest i
didn't see you i've been over to france
like two or three times i've never seen
a mustang over there
uh cologne hey bill i'm a 33 year old
young man
i say i say young because i don't own a
home or have kids and while that doesn't
make
a man i certainly it certainly makes me
a young boy man
yeah i know you're sort of extending
your adolescence i i did that for a good
40 something years i recently ran into
my ex's friend and we started talking
about everything that happened
uh she had questions about why we broke
up after a few minutes she asked me
about the cologne fight we got into i
barely remembered it we once had a
conversation where i said i'm not into
it anymore and i don't want to smell
like other dudes who bought the same
[ __ ] i didn't think much of it but
apparently she thought it was a red flag
that i didn't want to ever wear cologne
she told her friends i was immature in
that way
why is it a red flag to not wear cologne
i told her cologne was for college kids
and dads with office jobs and that
cologne was immature for people wearing
it her friends laughed and agreed she
said that my ex
has brought it up more than once i said
oh yeah three years together and that's
all she has to say
that sounds immature
her friends laughed i even said [ __ ]
there's better ways she could
there there's better
wait [ __ ] there's way better
things she could have complained about
her friends laughed even more i need
your opinion on cologne in general
i also need you to tell me it's okay
that i asked the friend out for coffee
to laugh some more we're hanging out
next week
um i don't know it sounds like you hit
it off with her
that's funny she said that my ex brought
it up more than once i said oh yeah
three years together and that's all she
has to say that sounds immature her
friend laughed i even said [ __ ] there's
way better things she could have
complained about her friend laughed even
more i need your opinion
uh my opinion is you're going to start
banging her and she's going to end her
friendship with her ex
that's what's gonna happen uh my
feelings on cologne
um cologne to me is an old guy thing and
i love old guys that wear cologne
there's something funny about them
they're still dying their hair they got
[ __ ] a gold bracelet
uh
the guy that has the hanger next to me
where i where i got the helicopter is uh
he's a cologne guy he's a [ __ ] badass
dude he used to fly in the israel uh
israeli uh military
you know he's got a really fast plane
and he has a [ __ ] robinson r44 and he
has this little helipad that he tows it
on and when i tell you that helipad is
just
got one inch on either side
you know or you're gonna fall off that
[ __ ] thing and he lands it on there
like a champ every time and he wears
cologne and i think it's great as a
young person i don't know i'll forgive
you if you're young but if you're
somewhere in between college age
and some old guy that used to fly for
the military of a country
uh yeah it's pretty cheesy
um
i would say if you want to smell good
just go with a really good smelling
lotion
you know it's good for your skin it
keeps your wrinkle free you look good
you smell good you got a little glow
going but it smells more like uh
it doesn't smell like you have a van and
you're gonna try to [ __ ] her on a water
bed i think cologne turns a lot of
chicks off i would think unless their
dad had it
um then you get into all that weirdness
whether he paid attention to her or not
they're gonna be you know
i've just been chasing that cologne
smell my whole life or like i'm a
daddy's girl all right
wife bitching about nudie nudity on tv
dear billy [ __ ] bastard [ __ ]
burr jesus
you just went with the cursing me out
version here hang on when i drink some
water i'm still dehydrated
linda billy blair over here
uh my wife you know what food poisoning
is really the poor man's colonic i'll
leave it at that
uh my wife recently threw a fit at me
watching the hbo series ballers
because of the amount of female nude
scenes she asked me to stop watching it
in front of her
uh did not respond to my
asking if she preferred i watch it in
private
i did not respond to my asking if she
preferred i watched it in private and
went on to on a whole tirade
about society objectifying women and
told me
i just watched the show because i want
to feel what it's like
to be built
like a [ __ ] brick house like the rock
and be able to get any chick i wanted
like him
well yeah i mean that's why you watch tv
and movies when i was growing up that's
the whole [ __ ] reason you watched it
burt reynolds all of those guys
they're all good-looking guys they had
mustaches and cool cars and all the
women wanted to bang them and i know all
of that is gone by the [ __ ] wayside
but i guarantee you to this day if
there's a good-looking guy and he's
pulling off a mustache and he's in a
cool car and he feels good about himself
and he's not really paying attention to
the hot chicks they're [ __ ] drawn to
him like a magnet it's just it's just is
it is what it is and don't let these
feminist
fours and fives these mediocre looking
chicks try to mind [ __ ] you and tell you
something different it is what it is hot
chicks will always like a cool guy in a
cool car who's not really paying
attention to him all right i told you i
wasn't in charge of casting i told her i
wasn't in charge of casting
unfortunately not able to choose
actresses she found unattractive slash
non-threatening ooh i mean you were you
went right forward i happened to fall
out of interest with the show anyway
since it's basically just entourage
which i love not saying anything bad
about [ __ ] entourage
uh with athletes instead of actors
also it's basically entourage with
athletes instead of actors
um is there a way guys can win this
argument though it seems the only way to
win it is by having it
is by not having it all in changing the
topic asap when it comes up but wanted
to seek your wisdom for better methods
that allow men to feel like they still
have balls socks and bruins suck go [ __ ]
yourself well the lovely nia just came
in first of all bill has no wisdom so i
don't know why you're asking him for any
kind of advice no look at you coming in
hot coming in hot come here gorgeous
coming in hot
um
all right so what's happening this guy
was trying to watch ballers with the
rock yeah and i guess there's a bunch of
nudity in there yeah and his girlfriend
got all upset a bunch of naked [ __ ]
yep
yeah she got all upset saying this
objectifies
women and you just you just want to
watch this show because you want to see
what it would be like if you were built
like a brick [ __ ] house
or a [ __ ] brick house however the [ __ ]
he's supposed to say and got to bang any
chick you wanted and i was like well
yeah yeah does that mean isn't that yeah
isn't that why
he's watching the show it's not why
everybody watches that's why my whole
time growing up watching movies would be
like what if i i was watching it like
what if i was good looking and knew how
to fight yeah what if i knew how to make
supermodels laugh and throw their head
back as they kicked their foot up
right
yeah yeah but i didn't i mean that's
probably why he's watching it so what's
the problem oh he's just like trying to
figure out how to watch his show in
peace
the problem is he thinks that she's just
you know
she doesn't like him looking at those
girls on the on a tv show that's what it
is because they're better looking
than she is let's not go there but you
know i'm sure she feels some kind of way
about him you know watching that yeah
sure okay so what do you think about
should he be allowed to watch he can
watch whatever he wants to wear exactly
yeah i don't think she should
try to stop him from watching it i think
he needs to find a different time to
watch the show that's probably a better
idea just watch it when she's not around
so you don't have these arguments do you
live together though is there no way
that you can watch you can't watch it on
your phone after she goes to bed
rolled over on the other side so she
can't see the light glowing from your
phone three in the morning watching
money
[Laughter]
in secret i actually i think that's a
great point to bring up to her it's like
am i really gonna have to watch ballers
at three in the morning on my phone once
just let me watch but i mean yeah and
her i think she's yeah probably doesn't
like the fact that i never watched that
show
but i'm sure
yeah because it's about athletes and
that whole lifestyle i think it's
athletes
that's what i said you said athletes i
said it's athletes and wait what is it
athletes athletes yeah not athletes
it's not athlete it's not athlete's foot
athletes
athlete no athlete at the leeds
i think it's athletes now i don't know
you've said it so much foot athlete
it's not
it's it's athletes
that's not athlete he's an incredible
athlete
oh you're right it's not it's not
athlete
athlete
[Applause]
my wife is dumb
athlete
all right yeah that makes sense um
so it's about athletes
athletes that's why you're saying
antholy oh i said it's about athletes
yeah now you said that doesn't sound
right
all right well that's the podcast i have
some stuff wait wait so what is what's
on this show that's so offensive it's
just like naked women or just scantily
clad like the groupie poor's yeah yeah
i'm watching a cautionary tale i plan on
being successful and watching this show
makes me love you even more and this is
why i'm going to stay with you i
appreciate you more now that i've seen
all these well you know i listen yeah he
just he can watch whatever you as long
as he's not running around trying to
have that lifestyle in real life it
really shouldn't be a problem you know
what's funny is if she was watching
magic mike and he had a problem with it
like the others that same woman would be
like where ed you know it's your own
insecurity and i'm just watching look
i've always liked music and i've always
enjoyed dancing
that's just what i'm watching
there's no nudity in that unfortunately
some sensual dancing but you know
yeah they never show dicks
not enough
yeah because a dick is a weird thing nia
yeah because when a deck is just
chilling it could it's you know it
depending on the temperature it can just
pull all the way up and no one wants to
go on camera it's got to be in like an
art it's got to be like a tasteful way
to see a dick because we're not like you
backlit would you backlight the dads are
just like boobs but i feel like if it's
a dick like a woman wants to see a dick
and like the proper contacts and like a
system what sort of lighting do you want
flat lighting or do you want like you
want shadows i i don't know [ __ ]
martin scorsese why don't you tell me
like what is the best way to light a
dick i don't know just trying to make a
joke
you were sitting there going like
there's got to be a proper way to show a
dick what was the best dick you saw in a
movie as far as like you thought it was
presented well it hadn't you know it's
something you'd want to ride i mean the
whole thing
now i'm thinking um i don't think i've
ever seen a dick that appealing in a
movie because it's usually either played
for laughs or it's just like really
quick well dicks are funny
like maybe can you give me that
dicks are funny dicks are funny yeah i
mean i mean if it when it's asleep it's
a dick is funny when it's asleep it's
funny yeah when they're waking up there
it becomes a completely different thing
it's like a bad drunk
yeah obviously i would prefer uh an
awake dick to a sleeping dick
but no i was just saying a sleeping dick
is funny
yeah i guess so it's fine like i don't
really you know it's whatever
all right i don't think about dicks like
that you know what i mean i've been with
the same dick for a while i don't want
to talk about dicks anymore all right
why don't why not you want to talk about
all the nudity on that athlete show
athlete
that's what i said you're saying athlete
athlete
thank you
you fixed me i used to say uh paulo you
go hallo nice i used to say pillow and
you and you said it's pillow not pillow
and then you go palo i never said palo i
said pillow say roof
roof okay you don't say rough
rough like a dog
[Laughter]
some people say rough
like some some white people say rough
go up there on the roof
no oh yeah up there on the roof yeah but
you say roof you know rough and i say
saturday i don't say saturday
all on saturday we'll get up on the roof
we'll i will take care of it what did i
hear you talking about don't let these
stubbornness these four or fives tell
you about what were you blabbering on
about
what were you saying why am i blabbering
because you just don't make any sense
you just open your mouth and loud noises
come out and that's
like your career for the last 30 years
i was just gonna say that's one that's
one of the most accurate descriptions of
me ever
bill how would you describe your comedy
i open my mouth and loud noises come on
i can't argue with any of that
um no i was just saying you know they
try to say like uh you know like
women who aren't pretty try to say that
the reason why i don't think they're
pretty is because society told me what
beauty is
okay you know like i look at beyonce and
i wouldn't think she was pretty unless
society told me that she's [ __ ]
gorgeous right i love how you reacted
like i was gonna say something bad about
her i was gonna because we were about to
get into a fight if you were so what oh
yeah what if i was gonna pick on some
beautiful white lady huh
reversed sexy lady person
uh no and it's just what were you saying
my point is don't let ugly people tell
you
who my point is it's like they'd be
attracted to what that ballers thing
well they're just sitting there you know
they act like you know whatever they get
all [ __ ] upset by this thing it's
like that's how the world is yes if
there's a jacked guy with a bunch of
[ __ ] money
who every time he takes a picture he
holds his cuff link and looks the other
way and he's not really paying attention
to the hot women and he has a cool car
they're coming his way yes it's thank
you it just is what it is they act like
the reason they're doing that is because
of society
who thinks that feminists
you know
they think that people are attracted to
guys that do that because of society yes
what does that even mean because i don't
know what it means yeah you don't sound
like you know what it means no no no no
no nia this is like a real thing they're
saying like in advertising
these impossible standards for beauty
and blah blah blah blah impossible for
you and possible for me we're not
beautiful
i don't know i mean speak for yourself i
mean no you're beautiful i'm not oh
yeah
[Music]
that's my point that's my point i think
you're very handsome and i get people in
my [ __ ] comments being like does your
husband have a girlfriend
you know so obviously somebody you know
what that means me wants to blow you i i
can tell you exactly i can tell you what
that means what does that mean that
means that she had a bald orange dad
that didn't pay attention to her i
didn't have a bald orange dad that
didn't pay attention to me
i feel like you're kind of insulting me
because you're making it seem like i'm
with somebody ugly are you making my
ugliness about you you're not ugly you
just have low self-esteem
all right yeah let's play let's play a
little game
let's play a little game this is so
[ __ ] stupid you want to talk about
somebody who will just argue anything
all right nia let's play a little game
you have to leave soon so let's wrap it
up brad pitt yes bill burr
which one
well bill burr obviously nia well
okay there we go
there we go
but like
billboard shut up i don't want to hear
the other one
i don't want to hear the other one
bill burr mr hooper from sesame street
go [ __ ] yourself all right that's the
podcast
that's the podcast everybody
enjoy yourselves
um athlete
did i say it right athlete yeah you said
it right athlete
pillow pillow
pillow pillow there you go all right
athlete pillow
um we're going crazy here hey send me in
the words that you said the wrong way
for the longest time until you started
dating somebody that loved you enough to
correct you and not let you walk around
like a [ __ ] going hey i want to buy a
couple of pillows all right
he's a really good athlete all right bye